[Musique]
bienvenue à radio canada international
ces contributions hebdomadaire canada je
suis votre hôte
aujourd'hui alice chantal jaden et mon
nom je suis en remplacement de notre
collègue stéphane parent qui est un qui
est indisponible pour des raisons
indépendantes de sa volonté
dans ce studio je suis en compagnie de
deux de nos collègues
samir ben jaffar de la section arabe de
radio à l'international
merci merci chantal de madame accueillir
aujourd'hui avec vous alors nous avons
également marc montgomery de la section
anglaise de radio canada international
bonjour bonjour bonjour alors ce que
nous allons faire c'est dans un premier
temps avec des avec des images qui lui
manque les boules avec les bat on va pas
faire l'amour à la plage on a en a pas
un autre boule magique on va jaser entre
nous est-ce que vous savez se bat on va
baisser
vous savez garder ce secret qu est ce qu
on veut aller allons-y
2010l'indice hospitalisation ça peut
être quand on avait russe mais on a déjà
un autre indice évoqué ensuite à sion ok
dit est-ce que c'est du soin palliatif
aux attentions actifs
ces classes qu'on n'est pas dans le
traitement du concerne mon non plus à
temps est ce que ce sont et mentale un
peu non non c'est bon allons y célèbre
médicale à mourir à on a une échéance
c'est le 11 mars
oui cette échéance a été donnée par la
juge christine baudoin way au
gouvernement fédéral pour procéder à un
toilettage de la loi canadienne de
suresnes l'aide médicale à mourir
et donc c'était relativement à un
jugement qui a été rendu par la cour
supérieure du québec et ce jugement
concerne et deux montréalais et puis
leur nom je crois c'est jean trichant et
nicole gratuit
donc c'est des personnes qui étaient qui
sont atteintes d'une maladie de général
et donc qui ont bénéficié de l'aide
médicale à mourir
sauf que la juge dans son jugement
estime que la loi est beaucoup trop
donc c'est les prêts sont
discriminatoires et discriminatoire il
ya et quand la constitution et contre la
charte canadienne des droits et libertés
et donc ottawa a lancé des discussions
en ligne pour le moment il est question
de recueillir dont les avis de la
population sur la façon dont il faut
procéder pour élargir cette loi il ya du
tout un débat ici au québec un début de
débat puis ça il ya eu comme une grande
glissade
oui parce qu'on s'interrogeait sur la
possibilité d'élargir les médicale à
mourir aux personnes atteintes d'asthme
de santé mentale comme 209 santé mentale
manger trois personnes présentant des
problèmes de santé mentale et donc ça
fait boule de neige si vous voulez et
aujourd'hui notre invité pour en parler
donc si nous va ben gaied qui est donc
la directrice à la recherche et au
développement à la fédération québécoise
à la société québécoise d'alzheimer
madame noix de benguet bonjour mangeant
mais c'est un plaisir de vous avoir ce
matin comment éviter à notre émission
tant au canada que vous suggérera tout
ce débat sur l'aide médicale à mourir au
pays en ce moment
alors en fait ce débat a quand même
débuter ici au québec depuis 2008 le
québec a été pionnier dans la discussion
et dallas dans la réflexion en proposant
déjà la loi sur les soins de fin de vie
qui a donc été adoptée en 2014 et qui
entré en vigueur en 2015
et c'est un an après que le fédéral a
emboîté le pas et donc a également
proposé l'aide médicale à mourir aux
personnes aptes à consentir aux soins il
y avait quand même une différence entre
les deux lois provinciales et fédérales
à savoir qui avait justement ce critère
de famille qui était transversale à la
loi
québécoise mais qui dans la loi fédérale
était il y avait la notion de mort
raisonnablement prévisibles comme vous
l'avez prévient mentionné donc le
jugement de la cour suprême au québec a
rendu ce critère de fin de vie anti
constitutionnel et donc le gouvernement
fédéral et provincial doivent maintenant
retourner à la table de réflexion et
proposait finalement une alternative à
ce critère là le québec s'est déjà
prononcée par rapport à ce critère là
qui maintenant ne fait plus partie donc
2 de la loi de soins de fin de vie est
donc pour le moment bien sûr les
personnes qui sont en fin de vie ne
peuvent pas encore recevoir l'aide
médicale à mourir mais elles ne pourront
donc dans dans certains dans quelques
semaines la étant donné que c'est un
critère n'existera plus dans la loi
cette province kian et veut justement
mentionné qu'il y avait un débat qui
entoure y dit maintenant cette question
pour d'une part élargir maintenant
l'aide médicale à mourir aux personnes
inaptes
il ya eu délit certainement à une
réflexion en tous les cas un début de
réflexion pour également l'élargir aux
personnes avec des difficultés de santé
mentale chose que la ministre de la
santé s'est déjà déclarée en faveur d'un
arrêt finalement de ce processus là pour
prendre le temps pour comme le temps de
la réflexion et je pense qu'on est
également là pour les personnes inaptes
en tous les cas qui seraient atteintes
d'un trouble cognitif majeures telles
que la maladie d'alzheimer et comment
réagissez-vous à la position de il ya un
collectif de médecins contre
l'euthanasie
il ya notamment monsieur racicot qui
estime que cette loi là sus à un suicide
incite les gens à prendre la décision de
mourir
donc comment réagissez-vous par rapport
à ça est ce que c'est une loi contre
l'avis dans le fond
en fait la loi sur les soins de fin de
vie a été d'une part établis avec un
consensus avec également 100 sans
partisanerie il ya eu énormément de
consultation auprès de la population des
commissions également sur les 510 où les
parties prenantes avaient l'occasion de
s'exprimer et la loi de soins de fin de
vie à a quand même plusieurs mesures de
sauvegarde qui empêche toute dérive à
savoir que d'une part la personne doit
être apte à consentir aux soins elle
doit également être majeur et assurables
par la régie de l'assurance maladie du
québec and white man il doit également y
avoir deux médecins qui se prononce par
rapport à la validité de la demande est
médicale à mourir
et encore une fois la personne
actuellement bien sûr doit être en fin
de vie atteinte d'une maladie incurable
irréversible et dans des conditions
avancées
donc les mesures de sauvegarde ont été
mis en place pour éviter toute dérive et
il n'y a pas eu dérive dans les quatre
dernières années ce qui manque que ces
mesures de sauvegarde joue totalement
leur rôle et que tout finalement toutes
les craintes qui avaient été formulées
au départ ne sont pas réalisés ce n'est
pas un chèque en blanc pour la mort
étant donné que c'est vraiment la
volonté de la personne de décider de
partir en toute dignité
sachant qu'elle est atteinte d'une
maladie incurable et surtout qu'elle est
apte à consentir aux 100g question selon
la loi c'est quoi la différence entre
l'aide médicale à mourir et l'aide
médicale assistée par un docteur alors
l'aide médicale à mourir et toujours
prodigué est donné par un médecin
c'est le médecin qui donne à l'aide
médicale à mourir qui est considéré
comme un soins de fin de vie donc non
seulement il faut
un à deux avis de médecins qui
finalement évalue de l'admissibilité de
la personne a demandé la médicale à
mourir cette demande et celle demandée
par la suite envoyé à la commission de
la soins des soins de fin de vie qui a
donc un mois un pouls pendant deux mois
pour émettre un avis de conformité parce
que la personne répond aux critères de
la loi et par la suite si le médecin
c'est toujours le médecin qui produit
que ce soit là est-ce que tu veux c'est
pas forcément la même situation dans
d'autres pays par exemple exactement
dans d'autres pays notamment la belgique
ou le pays bas on parle plus des deux
camps nazis
mais c'est toujours basé sur encore une
fois sur l'administration par un médecin
est-ce qu'on devrait par exemple suivre
le modèle de la belgique qui a étendu
cette aide là à toute personne souffrant
d'un problème de santé mentale
sa scène débat je pense qu'on en est pas
encore là encore avoir cette réflexion
il faut que les parties prenantes que la
société civile soit à l'aise avec avec
cette notion de détendre l'aide médicale
à mourir à des personnes avec des santé
des problèmes de santé mentale
actuellement le départ est plutôt
concentrées autour de l'élargissement de
l'aide médicale à mourir pour les
personnes inaptes notamment pour les
personnes atteintes de troubles
cognitifs majeur madame égalité avec la
décision de la juge qu'est ce qui va
changer ça c'est pour nos pour ceux qui
nous suivent
qu'est ce qui va changer à partir du 11
mars et ça que la loi devrait être
modifiée d'ici lancement qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est-ce qu'on a maintenant qu'est ce
qui devrait changer que ce qu'est ce qui
va se passer après le 11 mars
si on doit appliquer la décision de la
juge il y a deux volets il y à un niveau
fédéral et au niveau
on va dire au professeur là on est en
train de parler du niveau provincial est
ce qu'on pouvait un peu élargir votre
disque votre explication à l'ailé
fédéral s'il vous plaît alors pour le
moment donc comme je disais le québec a
finalement suspendu ou éliminer le
critère de fin de vie c'est ce qui veut
dire que à partir donc du 11 mars
prochain une personne qui est apte à
consentir aux soins qui est majeur qui
atteint d'une maladie incurable avancée
est irréversible on pourra demander
l'aide médicale à mourir et la tendance
excusez-moi de vous attend même si elle
est partiale et pas raisonnablement
mourante
c'est ça même si elle n'est pas en fin
de vie etc c'est donc maintenant au
niveau du fédéral
il ya encore des représentations au
niveau de la commission parlementaire
pour justement respecter ou en tous les
cas répondre à la demande de la juge et
donc pour enlever le critère de mort
raisonnablement président
ce qui veut dire encore une fois que le
fédéral devra devra on voit des départs
au québec les 7 lits plus rapidement
maintenant à à ce critère là qui devra
être supprimés étant donné que l'aja a
jugé qu'il était anti cons mais est-ce
que des problèmes avec la loi actuelle
c'est le fait qu'une personne peuvent
remplir toutes les critères un moment
donné mais veut pas mourir immédiatement
mais dans le délai il pense que les
questions apte à décider peut-être
quelque chose comme l'alzheimer par
exemple peuvent affecter sa kabylité de
décider qui a mené elle a dit oui je
veux mais à l'entretien il y à cette
problème qui arrive que maintenant et
elle ou il n'est plus habitable de
décider l'an tellement je vais ajouter
l'argent qu'elle intervienne on sait
qu'au québec il ya eu un comité
d'experts qui a réfléchi sur cette
question là et qui a fourni
les recommandations et là c'est toute la
notion du consentement préalable et le
fait de pouvoir désigner une tierce
personne pour je veux dire rappeler la
dernière volonté du patient au médecin
traitant
je sais pas si on abordera dans le même
sens oui oui
alors en fait il ya plusieurs choses
d'une part les il ya uniquement un tiers
des demandes d'un médicale à mourir qui
n'ont pas été finalement répondu c'est
d'une part soit parce que la personne
est décédée avant que avant qu'elle ne
reçoive l'avis de la commission des
soins de fin de vie soit parce qu'elle
est devenu inapte au moment finalement
où elle a reçu la réponse est donc elle
n'a pas pu avoir accès à l'aide médicale
à mourir
c'est sûr que maintenant il ya tout d'un
autre débat qui s'ouvre étant donné que
là maintenant on s'intéresse aux
personnes inaptes qui ne sont pas inclus
elles ne sont pas inclus ni dans la loi
fédérale est ni dans la loi provinciale
pour recevoir l'aide médicale à mourir
parce que justement il ya ce critères
d'aptitude à consentir aux soins est
également le critère finalement 2-2
même si elles sont atteintes d'une
maladie grave et incurable avec une
dégénérescence et un déclin cognitif à
avancer par contre elles ont été inclus
dans la loi québécoise au niveau des
directives médicales anticipé à savoir
qu'une personne qui est en soins de fin
de vie un fardeau qui est en fin de vie
qui également est atteinte d'un trouble
neuro cognitif majeure de type alzheimer
peut demander en fait de manière
anticipée à ne pas recevoir un certain
nombre de soins ils sont la respiration
cardiovasculaires qui est la dialyse et
l'alimentation et l'hydratation forcé ce
qui veut dire que lorsqu'une personne
maintenant vous moi on peut remplir nos
directives médicales anticipé d'ailleurs
il ya plus de 57 milles directive qui
ont été rédigées
est enregistrée au registre des
directives médicales anticipé mais c'est
un nombre infime par rapport finalement
au nombre de personnes qui pourraient y
avoir recours et donc maintenant en
étant apte décide que au moment où elles
seront inaptes de ne pas recevoir ses
soins est la conséquence de ne pas
recevoir ses soins à ces immeubles
inévitablement la mort mais maintenant
le comité d'experts dont vous mentionnez
justement à amy 14 recommandations pour
pour aller dans le sens d'un
élargissement de l'aide médicale à
mourir aux personnes une arme
il faut savoir que l'aide médicale à
mourir ne peut pas être demandé dans une
directive médical anticipées on ne peut
pas demander à a finalement à avoir
recours allaient aux soins dettes
médicale à mourir dans sa directive
médical anticiper c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas possible c'est uniquement
ces quatre soins dont je vous
mentionnais mais ce comité d'experts a
aisni justement 14 recommandations qui
rit en faveur d'un éventuel ouverture ou
élargissement de la loi sur les soins de
fin de vie peau des personnes inaptes
notamment dans des situations de
troubles neurocognitifs majeur vous avez
mentionné effectivement que la personne
de recours et demandé actuellement en
étant aptes à consentir aux soins qu'au
moment où elle devrait entre inapte
elles puissent avoir accès à l'aide
médicale à mourhino sonnait qu'une
tierce personne viendrait finalement
initié cette demande à me demande la
auprès du médecin tu sais tierce
personne pose quand même un certain
nombre de défis de questions cette pièce
de personnes peut également être une
une personne qui a un intérêt pour la
personne ça peut également être une
nomme une autorité externe impartial qui
donc pourrait initier la demande de tête
médicale à mourir dans des situations
d'inaptitude et donc là on se demande
quelle vague
le rôle de cette terre ce personnes est
ce que par exemple le curateur public
devra jouer un rôle tout à fait à l'aise
à mourir pour une personne inapte ça
pose énormément également de malaise au
niveau des médecins qui devront qui
devront prendre cette décision pour les
quatre définir quand est ce que comme
quand est-ce qu'il est le moment
finalement d'avoir recours à l'aide
médicale à mourir pour une personne
inapte puisque sk à ce moment là elle ne
pourra peut-être pas exprimé sa volonté
vous non plus âgés et donc et donc ça
pose énormément de deux défis et tout le
monde me sens ne se sent pas à l'aise
sachant qu'actuellement il n'y a que 3 %
des médecins qui donnent une aide
médicale à mourir et donc ça veut dire
également que tous les médecins ne sont
pas neutres ont certainement pas à
l'aise non plus à la donne et dans des
conditions d'inaptitude
d'où l'importance et pour la personne
qui sollicite l'aide médicale à mourir à
protéger sa demande par un art je sais
pas moi un art total on a entendu un
collectif d'avocats se prononcer par
rapport à cette question là récemment
c'est à dire lorsque la personne est
encore à prendre une décision éclairée
faire en sorte que sa décision soit
protégé dans le cas dans un cadre légal
pour donner plus de latitude aux tiers
qui va le représenter
après qu'il soit tendu entre parenthèses
légumes alors justement le forum du 27
janvier dernier a abordé cette question
est ce qu'on devrait avoir une demande
d'aidé médicale à mourir anticipée ou
une directive de demande médicale
anticipé parce que c'est toute la
différence finalement au niveau légal
et quelle est la portée ou la
responsabilité par la suite du tiers des
professionnels de la santé de respecter
les volontés de la personne qu'elle a
émises lorsqu'elle est lorsqu'elle était
apte à consentir aux soins est là en
fait c'est sur les avis sont assez vont
quand j'aime quand le sens d'une
directive
à savoir que c'est la personne finit ce
qu elle ce qu'elle veut recevoir quand
est ce qu elle veut recevoir
comment est ce qu elle veut recevoir et
encore une fois la cgt encore là on est
encore dans le flou on est au début du
débat je pense qu'il va y avoir il va
falloir préciser les critères pour par
rapport à cette directive ou à cette
demande anticipée d'être médicale à
mourir mais comme les directives
médicales anticipés actuellement elles
sont inscrites dans un registre donc le
registre dtm à la personne peut le faire
notarié ou pas tout ce qu'il faut c'est
d'avoir deux témoins lé témoin également
n'ont pas à connaître le contenu note de
la directive médical anticipé mais par
contre c'est le registre qui va
permettre par la suite le moment venu
aux professionnels de la santé de s'y
référer et la famille donc de pourra
dire donc aux professionnels qui lie à
une directive médicale en dissiper au
registre et donc ils ont l'obligation
il ya une obligation de respecter la
directive médical anticipées alors est
ce que c'est
c'est là qu'on veut aller en tous les
cas c'est a priori le consensus qui
semble se se proposait à pour que ce
soit une directive plutôt qu'une demande
mais encore une fois on me met encore
vraiment au début des conversations et
puis surtout qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses à ham a élaboré et à définir
avant de se dire est ce que c'est une
directive ou une demande notamment c'est
le camp le comment naquit qu'elle
lesquels également l'impact que cela
peut avoir sur la tierce personne qui
généralement est le conjoint
mais encore une fois ça peut être une
autorité externe
sachant qu'un certain nombre quand même
deux personnes ne sont en situation
d'isolement et surtout c'est les
médecins les médecins actuellement c'est
eux qui sont responsables donc de donner
l'aide médicale à mourir mais on le sait
très bien en dans une situation
où la personne devient inaptes ou elle
n'est plus généralement à domicile elle
est dans en hébergement de longue durée
est à priori c'est peut-être plus le
médecin de famille qui la suivait qui
est encore son médecin traitant et donc
bah ça suppose également une continuité
des soins
étant donné que actuellement l'aide
médicale à mourir et quand même donné à
80% par des médecins de famille donc
vous voyez il ya plusieurs choses à
régler a finalement à définir également
pour que si on décide d'aller vers un
élargissement des médicaments pour les
personnes inaptes ça se fasse avec des
mesures de sauvegarde très claire des
valises critères qui permettent vraiment
de protéger les personnes sont des
personnes vulnérables et donc qui qu'il
faudra protéger et confondre a toujours
respecté et traité avec dignité
même lorsqu'ils demandent donc la l'aide
médicale à mourir
donc c'est encore un débat je pense qui
est très large et que commence t mais je
pense qu'il faudra être très prudent
madame ben gaied mois de mars ou s'il
est toujours pédagogique
donc en ce moment si une personne est
inapte la seule chose qu'elle peut faire
c'est d'avoir une directive midi cadre
anticipé pour demander l'arrêt des soins
mais pas l'induction de la mort comme ça
se fait maintenant est ce que ces
personnes inaptes une personne inapte ne
rentre pas du tout dans les critères de
la loi elle ne peut ni demander l'aide
médicale à mourir ni avoir une demande
une directive dead alors une jusqu'à
anticiper les personnes ap
actuellement inapte ne sont pas du tout
considérés dans la loire
mais malgré ça oui arte auxerre
rapidement allez-y ça veut dire pardon
une personne actuellement inapte
atteintes de la maladie d'alzheimer ne
peut pas avoir recours à l'aide médicale
à mourir mais elle peut demander
auparavant
qu'on arrête les soirs pour qu'elle
puisse mourir naturellement n'ont même
pas ça étant donné qu'elle est n a eu je
pense que veut dire que au moulin
période où là les actes étaient aptes et
mais elle ou il devient inapte par la
suite
exactement effectivement donc une
personne qui reçoit un diagnostic d'une
maladie incurable des type alzheimer
actuellement et qui est encore apte le
sheed mois ce sont eux
rédiger une pour en tous les cas au 11
mars prochain il pourra rédiger une
demande d'être médical anticipé à il
faudra voir là pour le moment c'est
encore quelque chose qui n'est pas ok
c'est pas légiférer c'est la proposition
c'est une proposition actuellement le
seul critère qui va s'enlever le 11 mars
et le critère de fin de vie mais la
personne et doit encore être à adapte à
prendre la décision mais aimer je veux
conserver son droit initial lorsqu'elle
ne sera plus du sud mais je peux je peux
je peux demander l'arrêt des soins pas
l'aide médicale à mourir est ce que ce
n'est pas suffisant parfois où on est et
autres un autre débat à savoir c'est
l'acharnement thérapeutique
là effectivement là je veux dire une
personne apte peut demander à ne pas
avoir de pages et d'armement
thérapeutique la cc un autre c'est autre
chose c'est notre souci pédagogique
seulement c'est un tout autre débat
voilà je vais devenir un peu sur une
position du premier ministre du québec
françois legault
on se souvient lorsque tout ce débat a
été lancé il a dit qu'il était enfin sur
un plan purement personnelle qu'il était
pro vie et donc un peu en faveur de
l'acharnement inspiration
sauf que il a dit s'en tenir à la
volonté populaire à la volonté de la
population québécoise qui serait
largement ouverte à à ce qu'on élargisse
la loi et donc je me pose quand même
quelques questions quelques
interrogations par rapport à la
responsabilité du premier ministre
est-ce qu'ils devraient davantage
écouter sa population contre le
collectif de médecins
contre l'euthanasie qui sont totalement
enfin je veux dire c'est des avis qui
sont dos à dos je pense que ce débat-là
free appel à nos valeurs c'est un débat
qui est très également personnelle qui
qui est également parfois empreinte de
beaucoup d'émotion parce que soit on a
vécu une situation pareille ou un proche
a dû finalement se rendre jusqu'en fin
de vie et peut-être perdre de sa dignité
donc c'est un débat qui est très
empreinte d'émotion par contre la loi
sur les soins de fin de vie s'est fait
de manière comme je vous le disais
tantôt de manière très collégial anti
partisane avec un consensus et c'est
pour ça que c'est important de continuer
dans cette voie là étant si on veut
élargir l'aide médicale à mourir aux
personnes inactives a soulevé énormément
donné va il y en a qui y ont qui vont
refuser d'avoir recours à l'aide
médicale anticipée ou en tous les cas
l'aide médicale à mourir de manière
anticipée
il y en a qui vont faire ce choix là
mais je pense que quand tant que société
on doit y aller avec le consensus
on doit également par la suite si la loi
le permet il y aller avec les volontés
de chacun est respecté ses volontés là
que monsieur le premier ministre soit en
accord ou en désaccord avec l'endroit
je pense que ça doit se faire de manière
anti partisane rouler responsable dans
tous les cas la vulnérabilité de chaque
personne est prise en compte
également dans un souci de protéger les
personnes les plus vulnérables
il est vrai que le dernier sondage léger
paru en avril était en faveur prochain
sonia traite en faveur de l'avancement
de l'aide médicale à mourir donc mais ça
reste un show ça reste un choix
personnel
il n'y a que quatre mille demandes des
deux médicale à mourir qui ont été
formulées ces dernières années ça veut
dire que
ainsi post même si c'est offert même si
la loi le permet ça ne veut pas dire que
les gens se sont se sont empressés nous
demander et a surtout été demandé
également dans des situations de cancer
de personnes en fin de vie avec un
cancer incurable donc voyez c'est pas
parce que la loi le permet que les
personnes vont s'en prémunir
ça reste quand même un choix personnel
et pour le respecter
et encore une fois une personne advenant
elles deviennent nat et elle décide
qu'elle ait recours à l'aide médicale à
mourir de manière anticipée
ben si c'est son choix qu'il faudra le
respecter aussi bien une personne qu'il
ne formulera pas être médical anticipé
et c'est également son choix et il
faudra le respecter
je suis allé un peu sur les réseaux
sociaux pour voir c'est que les
canadiens et les québécois penser de ce
sujet là d'une façon générale il ya
toutes sortes d'avis il y en a qui
pensent que dans la future loi fédérale
on devrait intégrer une espèce de
définition conceptuelle pour que les
gens puissent décider de façon éclairée
comprendre c'est quoi un consentement
préalable c'est quoi la notion de
souffrance atroce
c'est quoi la notion de mort je veux
dire de condamnation de critères de fans
j donc il faut vraiment définir un
certain nombre de mots de deux concepts
pour que les gens puissent vraiment
décider en toute connaissance de cause
effectivement vous avez tout à fait
raison il doit y avoir une sensibilité
sensibilisation une information qui est
donnée aux personnes qui décident
d'aller vers les 10 km médicale à mourir
et d'ailleurs un chiffre qui est parlant
comme je le disais uniquement 57 mille
personnes ont eu recours à des
directives médicales anticipé et
certainement elles peuvent le faire
également de manière totalement autonome
sans l'avis d'un médecin
donc encore une fois il faut il faut que
les personnes soient connaissance de ce
que veut
une qu'on accepte qu'on refuse une
réadaptation cardiovasculaire une
réanimation cardio vasculaires est ce
que ça veut dire quelles sont les
conséquences d'avoir ou de ne pas avoir
sa dialyse
comment va se faire la limitation forcer
son refus ou son acceptation
donc tout ça doit être vulgarisée ça
doit être également
ça doit faire partie finalement de
l'information que donne un médecin à son
patient lorsqu'il y va
lorsqu'il va parler d'une demande d'
aide médicale à mourir de manière
anticipée
mais ça veut dire également qu'il faut
encore sensibiliser la population à la
présence de directives médicales
anticiper les professionnels de la santé
ne savent même parfois pas fait ce que
sait où aller les chercher
qu'est-ce que ça inclut ou qu'est ce
qu'elle est leur responsabilité par
rapport à cette directive est ce qu ils
doivent la la la suivre ou pas donc je
veux dire on est encore là doit
finalement elle est encore jeune et il
faut encore beaucoup d'apprentissage
beaucoup de formations beaucoup de
sensibilisation à faire à différentes
strates de la société auprès des
professionnels comme auprès des patients
comme auprès des familles mais en tous
les cas c'est pas un débat fascine et il
faut surtout de manière très sereine
tout à fait tout à fait et ce débat la
pose de toutes sortes de questions y
compris à des questions éthiques
voilà c'était très très éclairante et
madame donc noah ben gaied qui est
directrice à la recherche et au
développement à la fédération québécoise
des sociétés alzheimer
je vous remercie infiniment d'avoir pris
le temps de nous parler s'était vraiment
éclairant merci à vous patiemment pour
la même passion au revoir au revoir
alors les collègues jugés légers un
dernier volet à notre émission c'est
quoi votre image de la semaine à ok une
image qui vous à moi voir s'il y est
encore en rodage et l'image du médecin
moi aussi j'ai l'image de ce pauvre
medecin
nouaïmi qui avait entre vraiment à la
fleur de l'âge légal à l'ensad alerte
dans le cadre de cette maladie là du
combattant mais je change
ouais moi aussi c'est mon image la
semaine bien sûr le colon de virus mais
il faut tenir compte que ici au canada
le risque et dans plusieurs autres pays
au monde le disque est très minime
daf et demandé son aide pour ça mais
dans le fond de maladie qui est pire en
terme de mortalité
c'est là tout à fait oui certains de
5000 victimes au canada chaque année ça
c'est le petit nuance très large allant
d'ailleurs la semaine dernière on avait
un invité qui nous parlaient du style on
a tendance à dramatiser par rapport aux
gros navires us mais il fait beaucoup
moins de victimes que la grippe la
grippe saisonnière comme ça au canada
tous les ans et puis il faut également
mentionner que sur la base militaire de
trenton en ontario on a ces canadiens
qui étaient en état de confinement en
chine qui sont arrivés mais j'ai aimé
leur hôtel dans lequel ses autres
banques
ils ont droit il faille des enfants je
trouve que c'est intéressant maintenant
confinement pendant les cours
mais c'est mieux que dans le bateau au
nom des petites caves naturelles à toute
prétention du gouvernement écarte le
terme confine mal
ces nouvelles observations et une
observation mais c'est bien que sur les
bateaux enfin au japon là où les
chansons les gens sont confinés dans des
petites cabines eux qui sortent cinq
minutes juste 11 ans que à tenir
bien très près mais où ils sont très
très bien traités mais c'est sûr que ce
sujet là nous interpelle tous surtout on
a un nombre de bilans de victimes
oui on ne cesse d'augmenter aujourd'hui
on doit 150 31000 oui quand émile cas
avec plus de 600 personnes qui en sont
mortes
attends je ne suffiront à mort à
l'extérieur de ses cendres en assistant
aux philippines exactement on a refilé
pis 637 en chine morphine et 31200
mouchard et les trente mineurs et à
l'extérieur de la chine il ya 270 cas
tout à fait confirmé je pense qu'ici au
canada on a failli s 5 5,5 donc delà du
notariat qui sont tus 16 en colombie qui
a déclaré déjà en état de rémission
progressive
c'est brian a donc donc le risque il est
là quand même la propagation c'est un
nouveau virus
cette façon d'agir du gouvernement elle
est responsable il faut qu'il le fasse
c'est vrai que le virus de la grippe il
en tue plus mais on vend plus on a
beaucoup de on a beaucoup des changes
avec la chine dans otages et dans
l'ouest canadien où il ya une commune
forte qu'une forte communauté chinoise
et l'échangé il ya des échanges donc
classe de risque il est là bas tout du
tout comme toronto puis montréal aussi
et surtout à l'ouest mais toronto cet
énorme aussi le nom de deux personnes
qui ont descendance de connexion avec
les choses ils sont toujours un
mouvement de personnes de défiler avec
la mondialisation donc les déplacements
sont toujours là on n'est pas des yeux
descendant de détail faut également
mentionner la nécessité d'une solidarité
internationale lance a été maintes fois
soulevée par l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
on entendait encore le directeur général
bill oms le dire ce matin et en chine
il manque beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
matériel médical les masques les
appareils respiratoires sont en rupture
de stock et donc on a entendu le
directeur général lancé un appel
à une solidarité internationale surtout
les pays les plus nantis ne doivent pas
oublier les pays les plus pauvres qui
ont besoin d'un encadrement d'un appui
en particulier pour pouvoir contenir
d'éventuels cas et donc il ya cette
problématique là et puis à l'om est ce
qu'ils recherchent activement 675
millions de dollars pour soutenir les
laboratoires de recherche au canada
notamment on a notre laboratoire du bail
qui travaille activement à trouver un
vaccin contre ce que renault est
toujours en cavale est à montréal est
aussi si on a un centre qui fournit des
renseignements des éléments ce qui
concerne la protection parce qu'on a
quand même des personnes qui arrivent de
la bande sais pas si cette personne là
sont malades ou pas si elles vont
développer la maladie ou pas eu
d'inculpation ses 14 et 14 jours et en
attendant vraiment la population est
sensibilisée
il ya au québec également j'entendais la
ministre maken donner quelques
directives à ce sujet là ce matin
voilà donc le canada après pas sa
stratégie de riposte
un calme allez on lance la séance à la
stratégie voilà donc dans exactement
deux minutes on aura terminé mais on
serait parti vraiment sans dire un mot
sans revenir sur le cas de ce médecin
lancera l'air de vraiment j'ai le coeur
totalement brisé hier quand j'ai appris
qu'il était déçu lui c'est un
ophtalmologue
oui il y avait alerté ses collègues sur
ses collègues sauf que la police locale
l'a accusé de divulguer de fausses de
faut donc le pauvre il a été fustigée et
finalement il amène sa vie se marrent
sauver celle des et ce matin le
gouvernement chinois a décidé d'une
d'une partie chinoise ils ont ils ont
décidé d'une enquête pour voir qu'est ce
qui lui est arrivé
une enquête en mai six autres filles
d'âge trouve s'il avait compte qu'il
surprend c'est son alerte dès le départ
on n'en serait peut-être pas là
moi si tu as pensé qu' il a 34 ans il en
est mort je m'attends parce que pour moi
et je m'entendrai ce que les personnes
qui qui décède à cause du grand buzz
soit soir atteintes de maladies soient
plus plus âgés mais finalement on peut
en mourir un appel à toute la région
à tout âge ça peut arriver un peu tard
n'oublions pas il laisse une jeune femme
qui est enceinte qui va bientôt donner
naissance ça va l'aider
raison de plus pour avoir très mal donc
voilà nous sommes arrivés au terme de
l'opération 1 2 d'am-dam canada et bien
je vous remercie infiniment d'avoir pris
le temps de nous écouter écouter les
amis à la semaine prochaine va cette
fois stéphane sera de retour merci
beaucoup chantal des inversions fois
merci et merci à nos auditeurs
[Musique]